all right alex
yes where'd you grow up where you from
originally guatemala
um a town called san marcos which is
real near to mexico to the border from
mexico and uh tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents
growing up
um yeah my mother she she's a nurse
and my father he is a teacher
but they usually weren't home
because they used to work in another
town nearby
so my mother used to have a shift of
a night the whole day in 24 hours
and then two days out
which be she was only at home like two
or three days
at home and my father he was only on
weekends
so we pretty much grow up by herself
with my brother
and my grandmother used to taking care
of us
and she was an alcoholic she used to
be with us and so when we were
really kids i was like uh
11 10 years old and
my brother and i uh we we joined the
game the 18th street game
and this is still in guatemala yeah
this this is still in guatemala yeah and
uh
because i was the youngest of everybody
they used to put me to do
the bad jobs like
[Music]
i remember once uh i was study
in kids college
and they told me to
to see which ones of my friends
uh has a wealthy family so we can kidnap
him
and that was one of my my first year of
the
they let me let me do it there so i pick
up one of the guys uh
that he used to say that his parents
were wealthy
so one day they told me to to take him
out to the
to a place we where we used to to play
uh video games and i took that guy with
me
and that was all uh set up and that was
one of my
my first jobs we kidnapped the decade
that day and
[Music]
yeah we asked for for money to to their
parents
and which i remember that was one of my
worst experience because that was
it was a little a little bloody because
they cut one of his
fingers to send it to his parents
because they don't
they didn't believe that that was really
happening and so
[Music]
they said because it was one of my
friends that i have to do it
and so they gave me a pair of scissors
to cut one of his fingers and i really
was like
crying doing that thing i was i just got
one of his small fingers
and yeah we put it in our envelope and
we send it to
to his parents and that was one of my
my first jobs that they put me to doing
it and you were old
for me how old were you i was like 11
years old
yeah my brother he was like 14 15.
so yeah was was tough it was really
tough
because i didn't know but i was getting
to it
but i have no choice because they were
taking care of us so it was
my grandmother which was alcoholic
so it was between her or it was between
the guys on on the gang street
so you choose to did the game the gang
become
kind of like your new family yeah they
they were yeah and
like on the weekends we we came back at
home
like if if nothing happens like regular
basis
type of family and our parents they
they never knew that that we were part
of of the game
what what kind of other things would you
do um
i remember that we used to
to go up on on the buses to
[Music]
to rob all the people in there and
i remember once they gave me a gun i
believe that was a
22 and that was the first arm that was
carrying on my hands so we went up on
the bus
and we start like taking all
the earrings watches
cell phones and if they have a good
shoes we used to
take it out of them and
yeah there was another another job that
that i had to do inside of the the game
street because
we have like uh uh
how is it
we have to to get like certain amount of
money
or or do some some kind of things
and we we we're present that on
with the with the head of the the game
each
friday night so we put all together
and then we we have a party like each
like every
every friday friday night we have a like
a huge body we used to drink
smoking marijuana and all kind of drugs
i started to smoke marijuana
crack and drinking at the age of
12 i believe
and
yeah it was was tough it was like really
tough
growing up sorry
it was tough growing up like without
your
parents knowing the that we were
doing that kind of stuff but at the same
time we got no another choice because
we were like really into it and if we
don't do
what they tell us to do they will uh
kidnap my sister my little sister
and they would rape her so we have to do
whatever
whatever they say but we have to do it
how extreme did it get i mean were you
murdering people and things like that
yeah it's hard like this is pretty much
the first time that i'm
confessing this with anybody else
and it was
was it was really really really extreme
because i remember once we kidnapped a
little girl and she was
like my age at that time and they they
tell me to
uh to rape her and you know i was
so little i don't even know what to do
or how to do it and my brother
like it was my my left arm he used to
tell me
like what to do and how to do it at the
moment
but uh yeah that was pretty sad because
they were taking a video on a cell phone
of me of and the little girl like i was
having sex with her but it was awful
like really really awful because she was
crying
i was crying and i have to do it
and if i don't do it they will
you know take it against my
my family and that was the first thing
that i don't want them
to to know the what we're doing
did your family ever find out
not till we we were
i was like 19 years old
which was a year
a year before then then i got here in
united states
so before that i got here i i told
i told everything to to my parents and
they were
when we told them that because we were
supposed to be
catholic and we used to to go to the
church and
every sunday and we were like like good
kids
and yeah when we told them that they
were
devastating they were crying they were
saying that
if they would know that they will quit
their jobs
and they will stay with us
yeah sorry this is very
it's getting emotional for me
thank you
the gangs are very powerful in guatemala
right
yeah a lot a lot
and we used to because the
the gangster that we young uh we were in
charlos we were like like rockers type
of thing
and uh so we used to go to to han
cholos around the uh the city though
that i grew up
so we used to go like pretty much after
school
we used to go home cellos and
[Music]
with my brother and the rest of the the
group
we used to go and and beat these guys up
to so they we we took all their clothes
off because
we don't like the the trolls and stuff
like that
it was like a part of the thing of of
the game
because we were like rockers type of
thing
so yeah we used to
fight a lot one of my my first fight
i was like 11 years old
they put me to fight with another guy of
the 13th street
which was the rival again
he was like 14 years old he was older
than me
it was bad it was really really bad
because i never fight before i didn't
know what to do
the only fight that i got was with my my
brother and my cousins
when i was younger than that
and so i don't know i don't even know
how to dispel myself
but i would start fighting and
[Music]
i remembered that he punched me on my
lip
and my lips started bleeding which that
makes me
really angry and
so i stay because i was like
tall tall type of kid
and like in my country everybody is
short
and so this guy was shorter than me and
i was taller but i was younger than him
so i ended up kicking his his ass
then yeah he was
he was bleeding i like pretty much he
was
crying when one was fighting with him
and he started laughing at me
i didn't like that at all so i get even
angrier
and i ended up uh
like broking his nose because i remember
that
when i punched him the first time he
went on the ground when he went on the
ground like kick his
his face and
yeah so i grew up in a very intense
intense type of type of life
i saw blood was really bloody
bloody kind of life besides that my
my father he got he used to have a
roosters like rooster fights and
so i used to sew blood every
single day pretty much because that's
this kind of animals they
they're they're they're they're rough
they're yeah
roosters are very very yeah the roots
are very rough yeah
so i was like the murders that the gangs
would
would do would be against which kind of
people
uh pretty much there was used against
the
cholos which were the the 13th street
and because we're used to taking care of
our
our area our barrio and
yeah so we pretty much have a
like encounter fights i remember
once there was like a huge fight
uh and we have to uh call
uh like we used to get all together like
once every month like everybody
we were around
oh there was a lot around 80
members of the game and so we have this
big
fight against the 13th street which
they used to live on in a town
near near us and
we we got set up like a date
the time and everything that we're gonna
have the fight
so we get really organized
on that and we show up just like
20 of us but we were with a
blue chains machetes
baseball bats and
guns but guns they were the
it was like when when you fight against
another
another game like you're not
you don't use guns but you it's
it's weird it's it's really weird how
they how they got that kind of uh
rules inside of the game
but yeah that was really really intense
part of my
my life since you've been in the united
states what have you been doing
after i got here which was
it was 20 years old when i got here
i went to pennsylvania the first time
and i tried to get a
regular life like a normal life
i work in the kitchen they used to be
cook and how a
regular type of life i met my ex-wife
there in
in pennsylvania she's puerto rican
i have a my baby girl with her
now she's living in vegas
and it's been two years since i'm living
here in
l.a since i don't see my my daughter
so yeah after i moved from there i left
the gang and and everything and yeah i
started like getting or
trying to do to having a regular type of
life
and so today you're living on skid row
yeah
i'm living in ski room i live in saint
julian in sixth
and yeah after the the pandemic hits
it's been rough because i used to to be
a
cook and they used to
have two jobs and two different
restaurants
and they showed they shoot it down both
of them
from the same owner so after that i've
been
living on the streets pretty much so
it's because of kovid that you're living
here
because of khabib yeah yeah are drugs a
part of your life
yeah yeah they they've been
they've been being part of my life since
i was little so
yeah i'm doing heroin and crack
i'm heroin addicted and crack addicted
to
how do you support yourself now um
i do headlights i clean headlights of of
the other cars
and if not i do like uh
like a gigs type of jobs i go here and
there
or if no i help a friend he saw drugs i
sold drugs for him and
so yeah my life changed again
since i moved here in l.a
but it's tough it's off it's tough to
live on the streets
because you cannot sleep at night
it's a lot of crazy people i would say a
lot
people just screaming
[Music]
people trying to fight you
[Music]
and this stuff this stuff but uh
i grew up in a tough in a rough
type of life so i'm being used to it
how old are you now i'm 34 i'm going to
turn 25
in october and looking looking back at
your life you know
in guatemala you had a very treacherous
life and then
here i think you know things aren't a
whole lot better right now
uh not not as violent yeah it's not the
violent that they used to be
but uh when i used to live in vegas with
my
ex-wife i was doing good i wasn't doing
drugs or anything like that
i do it for like seven years
yeah like seven eight years but
uh when i moved here she don't let me
see my daughter
which that was one of the things that
hit me really bad
like really really bad and then after
that you start using drugs
and yeah i miss my daughter
a lot totally
what is your biggest regret in your life
left my family
but at the same time my ex-wife she
she got a really bad impairment so
she don't let me see my daughter and
i regret that every single day
she's gonna be seven years old
uh now and on may
and i really want to be there but i
don't think she
she'll let me
yeah and is your addiction
so strong now that you you feel like
you couldn't stop if you wanted to
you know so like covet seems to be
tapering off might be might be gone in a
few months or so
yeah then you can maybe put your life
into a new direction
is your addiction going to stop you from
doing anything
well that's the the whole point is the
yeah
go back to my normal life
but i'll be honest with you i don't know
if
i would gather the guts to do it
because i think that crack
i can i can i can do that but
heroin i don't know because when you
stop doing it
it hurts it hurts a lot your body hurts
you start getting aching
uh like you feel like fever type of
thing
so yeah i don't know if
if i would left heroin that easy but
i'm thinking about to to you know to to
go back to my
regular life and go back to work
to have like a decent decent job
i'm not like i'm stealing or doing bad
things to get money but uh
but yeah i would like to to have a
decent kind of yeah
so i go back to to
to have money to send money again to my
to my daughter if if she let me do it
because yeah she's she's her she's her
why is your daughter's mother not
allowing you to come back
uh is it drugs or is it yeah because of
the yeah
but uh when i quit i told her that that
that i i wasn't doing that she she
wouldn't believe me
and she wouldn't let me see my daughter
because of the same thing
and because of the same thing i used to
to
because i i miss her a lot
so i started doing drugs again
but i'm thinking about it quite i hope
i really hope that i'll do it this time
and with the interesting
life you've lived what what's the most
important thing you've learned
in your life
family do not let them
alone because you don't know
uh how their their childhood it's gonna
be like
i don't want my my daughter to have the
same type of type of life
that i had the same childhood that i
have
but uh her mother she's she's a good mom
she's a really good mom and
so yeah that's that's what i think
that it's one of the the most important
things in life
family
yeah all right alex thank you so much
for sharing your story
thank you very interesting thank you
thank you thank you very much
you